from living off of food stamps to
becoming an internet millionaire this is
a surprising story of michelle phan hey
it's Evan Carmichael I believe that
whatever goal you have the fastest way
to accomplish it is to model success
find people who've already done what
you're trying to do and apply their
strategies to help your business grow so
today I'm going to be looking at how
Michelle Phan went from living off of
food stamps to becoming a
multi-millionaire YouTube entrepreneur
and the top three lessons that you can
learn from her success okay so you may
know her for her hair makeup on beauty
videos but Michelle Phan is an internet
entrepreneur on a mission to have a
positive impact on the world she has one
of the most popular YouTube channels
online with millions of subscribers a
book deal a talent agency and a makeup
business that does over a hundred
million dollars in sales but it wasn't
always so easy for Michelle Phan growing
up she moved around a lot as frequently
as six times in a year she later found
out that was because her dad had a
gambling problem he would gamble away
all of their rent money and they'd get
evicted and have to move she didn't have
very many friends growing up because she
moved around so much and she was shy she
also was often one of the only Asian
kids at her school and so she got picked
on a lot her response was to turn
inwards and draw she would draw
princesses and fairytales and
superheroes and imagine that she was off
saving the world things got worse for
her at home her father left for some
unknown reason and her mother later met
someone else and remarried but he was an
abusive man and they struggled to get by
often relying on food stamps for support
her mom and her stepdad argued a lot and
every time they did Michelle turned
inwards again and drew as she got older
she wanted to wear makeup and bit by bit
her mother let her for her makeup was
like drawing on your face and she could
become the superhero that she wanted to
be growing up her mother wanted her to
be a doctor her family was Vietnamese
and in Vietnam doctors were respected
and revered and were important parts of
the community and so she enrolled in
critical studies but at 17 went to an ER
one day and found horrible things like a
pole being driven through a man and she
decided that it wasn't for her she said
I can't do this I'm pretty sure someone
else can do this but it's not for me
that same day she went home to tell her
mom that she could not be a doctor
anymore and that she was going to try to
find a way to make money being an artist
her mother was devastated so
reassuringly Michelle told her don't
worry mommy I won't become a starving
artist I'll find a way to take care of
us all doing something I love that's a
promise and I don't break promises so
here's how she did it and made her
mother proud lesson number one is do
what you love as a teenager Michelle
Phan started a personal blog talking
about her fantasy life she wished she
lived with lots of money and time to get
dressed up she took a waitress job as a
way to make money because she got turned
down to work on a local Lancome Beauty
counter they said she didn't have enough
sales experience she did her first
makeup tutorial in response to two
readers on her blog who asked her how
she did her makeup she felt it'd be
easier to show it than write it so she
created a seven minute video response
and put it up on YouTube she initially
thought only those two girls would watch
it but soon found people asking her to
do more and more videos she kept making
better videos because she loved helping
people and slowly the videos got better
and better videos like how to make a
facial mask at an unscented organic
kitty litter and how to get Lady Gaga's
eyes makeup tutorials took off and
rocketed her to stardom
she loved what she did and it came
through in her videos do what you love
number two is model success Michelle
Phan wanted the focus of her channel to
be on teaching so she looked at teachers
who inspired her especially Bob Ross
Ross was an American painter and TV host
he was a creator of the joy of painting
a TV program that taught people how to
make oil paintings and broke it down
into simple steps Michelle loved his
soothing voice and how even the casual
viewer could learn the paint from
watching the show too
this day she still plays Bob Brahms
tutorials in the background of the room
when she's working as a way to relax to
expand his business Ross started selling
his own art supplies and how-to books
today Michelle Phan has her own line of
makeup supplies in a book you don't have
to figure everything out for yourself if
somebody has already done what you're
trying to do model their success even if
they're from a different generation and
number three is partner up as Michelle
Phan grew in popularity she wanted to
have a bigger impact on the world and
she recognized that partnerships would
get her there faster her first break
came when an executive at Lancome the
company that wouldn't hire her for a
counter job because she didn't have any
sales experience googled around and
found one of her tutorials where she was
showing people how to apply makeup on a
plane they reached out and signed her as
a spokesperson she has continued to
partner with companies to make her own
cosmetics line with L'Oreal called M
create a talent network with n the mall
beyond launch a record label with
cutting edge group and release a book
with Random House she wanted to inspire
more people and build her business
faster forming partnerships helped her
get there and they can help get your
business off the ground as well I
started filming on YouTube on my webcam
in college in my room like just doing
makeup tutorials and now now like I work
with L'Oreal and I have like three
companies that I'm a CEO of so it's
incredible how that all happened because
I had a passion and it all started from
a webcam and it doesn't matter how small
your beginnings are it doesn't matter it
just it just all that matters is how big
your passion is so remember do what you
love model success and partner up and
who knows you might become the next
Michelle Phan and of course believe
thank you for watching and if you have a
suggestion for an entrepreneur you'd
like to see me profile leave it in the
comment section below and if you liked
this video and you want to see more
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you soon
self-improvement books are like Fitness
books they never work on their own what
you need is a trainer that's even get
the newsletter
you